it's like death staring at you when you
look at a camera
it's kind of scary also
[Music]
i'm speaking to filmmakers or future
filmmakers
you have to know i have gone through all
of this i have
learned it all on my own
[Music]
this is good i know there's something i
can pass on
for example i do not use a storyboard i
think it's a
instrument of the cowards
[Music]
acting and working with actors permits
chemistry
understanding the world and
understanding human beings
hold the camera don't look at the flip
screen look through it
there's one book i would ask you to read
if you want to make films
you spend way too much time in the film
school
it costs way too much money you can
learn the essentials of filmmaking
on your own within two weeks and i see
young filmmakers who come excitedly at
me and they say
oh i shot 450 hours my heart
sinks we are not
garbage collectors we are filmmakers
we are thieves we get away with loot
from the most beautiful or the most
scary or the most spectacular
places that you can ever find just hit
and run and get away with film i'm
werner herzog
and this is my master class
you